hey kids today we have a very special
guest officer dan hi kids we're going to
learn everything you kids need to know
about the police
yeah number one police officers have
cool lights on top of their cars super
cool
number 2 police officers wear neat
badges pretty neat number 3 police
officers have no legal obligation to
protect you from imminent harm it's true
i can sit back and watch as someone
stabs you repeatedly
yeah that really happened a subway train
in new york the victim himself had to
disarm the serial killer who the cops
were there to find look it up it's
settled law yeah it's kind of amazing
number four if you're too smart you
cannot be a police officer score too
high on an entrance exam and some places
won't let you into the police academy
they think you'll get bored and quit
number five the more arrests an officer
makes the more court appearances are
required which means more overtime and
larger retirement benefits oh yeah we
call that pension spiking i can retire
at 45 with more income than the mayor
it's a perverse incentive structure and
i can keep that pension even if i commit
murder
number six
some police officers get to work with
doggies the only dogs we don't shoot on
site number seven police officers can
violate your rights and get away with it
that's called qualified immunity number
eight becoming a police officer takes a
lot of training it took me three and a
half months to become a police officer
it took mr barber two years and three
exams to become a licensed hair stylist
yeah well scissors are sharp number nine
cops aren't required to know the law
even as they arrest people for breaking
in i can pull you over and search your
vehicle without any legal justification
as long as i think i have justification
anything i find is admissible in court
are you serious is that real we have
very good unions holy sh number 10
police officers get paid with our taxes
police misconduct is also paid through
your taxes so
we paid you to protect us yeah you don't
legally have to do yup that's civil law
and then
when you accidentally or intentionally
violate us you pay for all that too
wow that's really dude
oh
the police car has a cool siren ha ha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you